I use my rife every single night for breast cancer for the past week when I wake up at night and in the morning I am very dizzy.
I rad in the rife handbook to make sure you drink lots of water when you see the rife.
If so, does that mean at night or is it okay to drink enough adequate amounts of water during the day?
Also, it is possible to program that the program on my rife needs to be changed.
I am doing very well. Also, could the disease come from supplements I am taking?
So, the dizziness is, you know, so can you get dizzy because you are dehydrated?
So, that is the initial thought in this question as that the rife handbook is make sure
you drink in plenty of water while every therapy you are told to drink plenty of water.
They do not want you to be dehydrated. But the reason is that cellular dehydration can bring
about lots of other issues and it can affect the effectiveness of different therapies.
However, dehydration is typically not your first thing you think of when you think of dizziness
upon a rising and dizziness upon a waking.
So, you really want to ask a few more questions. If you feel when you stand up from a sitting position
or you get up and stand up or even sit up from a lying position and you feel a little bit woozy
but then you hold that for 10-15 seconds and it passes and then you're fine.
Really, what that suggests is adrenal insufficiency.
So, your adrenal gland kicks in a horrible that constricts your blood vessels
thereby increasing your blood pressure to shunt blood to your head
so that you have adequate oxygen supply upon rising from a sitting or lying position.
That's how fast that hormonal progression works. You're going to sit up from a sitting position,
sit up from a lying position. You literally get at least ten points elevation in your systolic
blood pressure because of a sympathetic tone stimulation, because of a hormonal release
in order for you to get adequate oxygenation to your brain.
So, if you don't get that, if that doesn't happen, that is a side of adrenal insufficiency.
So, if that's the case, if you'd say, if the person says,
what I get up at the middle of the night, I feel a little dizzy and then it subsides
matter of a couple seconds to 20 seconds and then I find, but I just got to kind of brace myself
before I start walking. That's a side of adrenal insufficiency. So, you really need to think
of taking some adaptogens, some adrenal stimulation. We have plenty of adrenal type things
to take. It could be a side of low cortisol in the middle of the night.
If you don't get, if that does not happen during the daytime,
it's most likely you have enough and you have enough blood sugar, but also be a side of low blood sugar
in the middle of the night. So, I don't think it has anything to do with hydration, and I don't
think it has anything to do with the rif, and I don't think it has anything to do with any of your
supplements taking. It's low blood sugar, low adredals, and the adredals need sugar, and your brain
needs sugar in the middle of the night. So, if you're already on a very low sugar diet because of
your cancer, and you're keeping your glucose at low levels, and this is only happening at night
than it's most likely cortisol or glucose or a combination thereof. So, try, I would suggest you
try adding some adaptogens, or eating some protein before you go to bed. So, it's not about
eating sugar, but it's about having, you know, not being hypoglycemic in the middle of the night.
So, eating some protein that's going to break down slow. Well, help maintain healthy. We'll do
both things. We'll help maintain healthy glycogen stores in a source of glucose, and a source
stimulation of cortisol at night.